au procès du sénateur déchu une nouvelle
fenêtre sur le travail de coulisses qui
a été menée pour protéger mike de filles
dans ce document déposé en cour des
extraits d'entrevues de courriels offre
un aperçu des efforts déployés dès le
début de la crise par l'entourage du
premier ministre pour justifier les
allocations de résidence de mike duffy
pour le protéger pour garantir son
silence surtout dans un courriel à des
collègues
nigel wright l'ex chef de cabinet de
stephen harper explique le but c'est
d'isoler mike et de l'empêcher d'aller
sur des tribunes publiques pendant les
fins de semaine la grc est catégorique
et elle affirme devant les tribunaux que
pendant l enquête le rapport est arrivée
jusqu'aux bureaux du premier ministre
lui même
7 à nouveau c'est arrivé là-bas pour qui
plus de trafic et pour des révisions
alors que senna préparait son rapport de
vérification interne
les pressions se sont intensifiés pour
atténuer certains passages concernant
les réclamations de mike duffy
la sénatrice caroline stubbe olsen est
l'une de celles qui a réclamé des
modifications à plusieurs reprises un
point tel que jean joseph la
vérificatrice de la chambre haute
d'iran aux policiers la sénatrice sur
lawson voulait qu'on supprime encore
plus d'éléments du rapport pour moi ce
rapport devenait très metz il y avait
très peu pour justifier un remboursement
qui avait déjà été fait
la principale intéressée a refusé de
commenter ces nouvelles allégations
affirmant qu'elle ne pouvait rien dire
caroline se relancent une devrait
témoigner au procès de mac de file tout
comme plusieurs membres de l'entourage
du premier ministre
difficile cependant de dire quand ils
pourront livrer leur version des fait
surtout que le procès qui a déjà
beaucoup de retard prend une pause de
trois semaines
dès demain et si daniel thibault radio
canada ottawa